these stories from tonight number one
how did I get this yeah yep that's
Patricia Arquette hitting the red carpet
in a viking hat it's one of the must-see
moments from the Golden Globes after
parties et was inside some of the most
exclusive bashes of the night and we're
breaking down all the deets
starting with Patricia and that helmet
at the FX Disney hula party I'm a Viking
in case you were wondering don't mess
with me
but Kings are dangerous she dished about
the style choice to et and explained how
she injured her the act co-star Joey
King with it when we went backstage they
were taking pictures he had all these
props and me and Joey were taking a
picture together with this and I picked
this making now I decided well I'm just
gonna keep it with me now while we're
taking the pictures
Joey's behind me dancing around and I go
like this she moves forwards bang I bang
her on the head she's got this giant
knot on her head so dee dee I can't
stand it like I injured Joey tonight
it's horrible and look she looks like a
butterfly or a moth or some kind of
I mean incredibly beautiful Billy Porter
was at the same soiree looking fab in
head-to-toe white complete with a
show-stopping diamond Tiffany necklace
diamonds are boys what are the carrots I
don't know and I'm not talking about
that part okay I'm not talking about
that part I don't have arm
I was gonna go no we're not talking
about that yeah he also revealed this
interesting red carpet secret what's a
secret about the look maybe a red carpet
secret we got about the look any any
special tricks my liver is broke and
it's been broke all night don't you all
worry about it I'm covering it up now
are you standing strategically or what
are you doing no I'm doing this as you
can see I've been doing this all night
my peppers broke then there was the
Netflix after-party where get this guys
both Jennifer Aniston and Brad Pitt were
in attendance okay so we don't know if
the two mingled at the party but it was
a big night for them both were nominated
for awards Brad for Best Supporting
Actor in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
and Jen for Best Actress in the morning
show
of course the two were married from 2000
to 2005 before they split but have
managed to stay friends yeah friends
that's a straight-up quote from Brad
himself
okay the obsession the world the
internet everyone is waiting they're
hoping for this moment where you and
Jennifer run into each other so they can
take their picture she's a good friend
yeah so they can you know how this goes
the second the second most important
reunion every of her year you know how
that works play on friends and then they
were saying that anyways cute and while
Brad and Jen may not have posed for the
cameras Jen did cozy up to Sandra
Bullock for this epic party pic
Tiffany Haddish was also at the bash and
got the crowd going behind the DJ booth
with a drink in one hand and the mic in
the other former co-stars Laura Dern and
Ellen DeGeneres were also in attendance
and celebrated their globes honors
together posing for this sweet pic with
Ellen's wife Portia de Rossi then there
was the InStyle party where some serious
TV cast reunions went down Coach Taylor
and Tammy forever yep that's Friday
Night Lights stars Kyle Chandler and
Connie Britton Connie also had a little
fun with her American Horror Story
co-star Dylan McDermott
[Music]
there was also a One Tree Hill reunion
in the elevator that Sophia Bush Brian
Greenberg and Danneel Harris but that's
not all big little eyes stars zoe
kravitz and shailene woodley cozied up
at the party - Oh ended an epic twinning
moment zoe post for this cute mama
daughter shot with her famous mom Lisa
Bonet
Haley Bieber also attended the bash sans
Justin rockin a mini dress with black
heels and new mama Shay Mitchell looked
absolutely gorgeous with her pal Kat
Graham but she wasn't the only new mama
out on the town Sunday night ET caught
up with succession star hearing Culkin
at the HBO after-party and he revealed
the epic reason his wife Jaz missed his
show winning globe gold you know our
show one that was did you see that house
that was the thing my wife was in the
bathroom pumping breast milk when my
category came up so I'm there next to an
empty chair going she's pumping
I actually really hope I don't win right
now because I don't want and then I
didn't know like okay sweet and then it
was our category and I was like she's
still not back and then we won I got on
stage and the whole time I'm just like
she still she could she brought the hand
pump which just takes longer so you know
it was a lot she got like over three
ounces yeah a lot of pumping what a
night X run ins reunions and Viking hats
oh my but I think the big takeaway is
what would Patricia Arquette do I feel
great and I know I look so like some
wearing a viking hat but we have to
enjoy our lives okay let's have some fun
already of course you can count on ET to
bring you all the breaking news this
awards season so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]